what happened you know once Colin and I
did something we thought would be really
funny he hit out front when I ran to
tell my mom but he had been hurt you
know hit by a car or something really
bad like that and when she came running
he was opposed to jump out and surprise
her and then we all had this great laugh
me and my mom and you always loved a
good laugh I was about eight or nine and
Colin he was like 11 I don't remember
how they came up with it but you know
sure enough I started yelling and
screaming and my mom comes running out
the house and she's like Trish what's
wrong what's wrong when I told her I
mean the look on her face
I mean even when Colin popped up to show
that was just a joke she couldn't stop
crying she held him close no what's
doing yeah I was just a baby I didn't
get it then but I get it now
Khan's dead
and no matter how hard I cry he's not
gonna pop up and show me that it was
just a joke